[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
metry Sirin hallo und guten Abend
Christian Ottos wieder bei mir im Studio
Handball und Tennisspieler
guten Abend und dann schauen wir auf das
was wir heute für Sie vorbereitet haben
tragischer Hubschrauberabsturz bei Kiew
mindestens 14 Menschen sterben darunter
der Innenminister der Ukraine und
mehrere Kinder
BASF Winterzeit zieht sich aus dem
umstrittenen Russlandgeschäft zurück
Milliardenwerte fallen an den russischen
Staat
und Schulleiter schlagen Alarm
Lehrkräftemangel gefährdet die Qualität
der Bildung in Deutschland
[Musik]
ukrainespräsident selensky spricht von
einer furchtbaren Tragödie nahe Kiew
stürzte am Morgen ein Hubschrauber in
der Nähe eines Kindergartens ab
mindestens 14 Menschen verlieren ihr
Leben darunter Ukraine ist Innenminister
und mehrere Kinder der Absturz wirft
Fragen auf ob verhängnisvolles Unglück
oder möglicherweise Sabotage dass wir
derzeit untersucht aus der Ukraine Tim
Kröger ein Flammen Inferno an der Stelle
an der der Helikopter in der Nähe eines
Kindergartens und eines Wohnhauses
abgestürzt ist es soll sich um einen
Hubschrauber des ukrainischen
Rettungsdienstes gehandelt haben der auf
dem Weg zu einem Freund Abschnitt war
die Leute haben geschrien und alles hat
gebrannt es ging von dort aus von den
Müllcontainern es war sehr groß es war
Feuer schlimmes Feuer alles flog
auseinander und brannte
wir hörten eine Explosion wir rannten
raus meine Tochter rannte zum
Kindergarten und meine Enkelin zu holen
alles dort hat gebrannt auch die Autos
vor dem Hausnummer 19
der ukrainische Präsident selenski
kondolierte und sprach von einem
unaussprechlichen Schmerz unter den
Toten sind auch hochrangige Vertreter
des ukrainischen Innenministeriums sowie
der Minister Dennis monastirski selbst
er ist das Rangliste ukrainische
Regierungsmitglied das seit Beginn des
russischen angriffskriegs ums Leben kam
ein junger Mann sehr patriotisch der
viel getan hat für die Ukraine etwa die
Umsetzung der polizei-
es ist eine große Tragödie
der ukrainische Geheimdienst zieht
verschiedene Ursachen für den Absturz in
Betracht ein Verstoß gegen die
flugvorschriften technische Probleme
oder eine gezielte Zerstörung des
Helikopters die Ermittlungen in
verschiedene Richtungen laufen noch aber
gibt es keine gesicherten Erkenntnisse
mitten im fürchterlichen Kriegsgeschehen
werden Forderungen aus der Ukraine nach
deutschen Kampfpanzern immer lauter
insofern wurde die heutige Rede des
Bundeskanzlers beim Weltwirtschaftsforum
mit Spannung erwartet auch weil man sich
international einen offensiveres
Vorgehen Berlins schon lange wünscht
Susanne Biedenkopf über den schmalen
Grad zwischen Erwartungen und
Enttäuschung
eigentlich wollten sie beim Treffen mit
der ukrainischen First Lady über den
Wiederaufbau für die Ukraine sprechen
doch dann erreichte sie die tragische
Nachricht vom Absturz des Hubschraubers
Oliver silenska fassungslos
das Weltwirtschaftsforum überschattet
von der ukraine-krise und das gilt auch
für die Rede des Bundeskanzlers über
allem die Frage wird er der Lieferung
von Kampfpanzern zustimmen was viele
Regierungschefs hier gefordert haben
Scholz vermiet eine direkte Antwort wir
leben die Ukraine so lange unterstützen
wie es notwendig ist
das reichte vielen im Saal nicht ein
ukrainischer Journalist fragte nach nur
zögern der deutschen verhindert die
Panzerlieferungen warum zögern sie
wollen verhindern
und der NATO das ist doch im Sinne der
Ukraine so wie ich das nach meinen
Gesprächen mit ihnen verstehen
repräsentiert die NATO Jens Stoltenberg
weiß um die Gefahr einer Eskalation aber
erneut plädiert er für weitere
Lieferungen schwerer Waffen ohne
Kampfpanzer direkt anzusprechen
wir brauchen mehr Unterstützung mit
schweren und modernen
waffens der Druck auf Scholz wird weiter
wachsen am Freitag treffen sich die
Nato-Verteidigungsminister in Ramstein
um über die Ukraine zu sprechen
wir gehen ins verschneite Davos zu ultra
ulfes gab im Vorfeld deutlich
Erwartungen zu Panzerlieferungen vom
Kanzler heute dazu nichts wie fallen die
Reaktionen aus
als ich glaube schon dass viele
europäische Regierungschefs doch sehr
enttäuscht sind dass Olaf Scholz
Bundeskanzler Scholz sich so gar nicht
bewegt hat in der Frage sondern hart
geblieben ist fehlen Europa befürchten
dass Deutschland sich damit isoliert und
das ist ein großes Problem weil in einer
zentralen außenpolitischen Frage spricht
Europa eben nicht mit einer Stimme
nämlich mit der Frage wie unterstützt
man die Ukraine da gibt es einmal die
große Gruppe der Länder die sagen wir
brauchen diese Kampfpanzer für die
Ukraine damit die Ukraine militärisch
überlebt und die Russen zurückdrängen
kann und da gibt es eben dann doch Olaf
Scholz der ihm davor warnt das weitere
Lieferung vielleicht auch sein
Eskalation mit Russland führen dieser
Unterschied spaltet Europa und ich
glaube auf lange Zeit ist das nicht gut
und es wird weiter der Druck auf Olaf
Scholz wachsen und möglicherweise gibt
es Ende der Woche ja Bewegung in der
Sache warten wir es ab danke nach Davos
es gibt ja nicht nur internationalen
Druck in Sachen kampfpanzerlieferungen
darüber wurde heute auch im
Verteidigungsausschuss des Bundestages
beraten die oppositionelle Union fordert
seit Wochen Leopard Panzer für Kiew und
auch Teile der Ampel sprechen sich seit
langem dafür aus mehr von instrums
liefert er den Leopard oder nicht
Kanzler Scholz zögert noch doch er steht
unter Druck europäische Partner wollen
im Verbund den Kampfpanzer an die
Ukraine liefern Thema heute auch im
Verteidigungsausschuss die
Koalitionspartner liberale und Grüne
wollen den Leo schicken und werden
ungeduldig als Grüne haben wir natürlich
sehr begrüßt dass die Bundesregierung
endlich den Entschluss getroffen hat
auch Marder zu liefern aber gerade vor
dem Hintergrund dieser Entscheidung kann
man glaube ich schwer begründen warum
man jetzt beim Leopard Schluss machen
sollte da ist Bewegung drin es ist immer
bedauerlich dass man immer schieben
schieben schieben muss ich bin
vorsichtig optimistisch wir werden sehen
der zukünftige neue
Verteidigungsminister könnte sich sehr
schnell in unser Herz erobern wenn er
quasi mit seiner Ankunft diesen Schritt
mitgehen würde diese Appelle richten
sich nun an ihn den designierten
Verteidigungsminister Boris Pistorius
jetzt geht's darum dass sie die
Bundesregierung gesichtswarnt aus ihrer
bisherigen Positionen herauskommt
das ist jetzt eine gute Gelegenheit es
wird höchste Zeit und wir werden das als
Union natürlich auch forcieren aus der
SPD Signale dass ich der Kanzler am Ende
der Woche doch zu einer panzerlieferung
durchringen könnte es gibt bei dieser
Frage ja Lieferung von Leopards oder von
schweren Kampfpanzern keine roten Linien
das gibt die Aufforderung gemeinsam zu
handeln das wird man den Rammstein tun
und dann wird man miteinander
entscheiden was ist denn überhaupt
lieferbar und der Druck nimmt zu das
EU-Parlament fordert den deutschen
Kanzler heute auf einen europäischen
Verbund zu bilden um Leopard in die
Ukraine zu liefern der Appell ist nicht
bindend aber deutlich
der russische Angriff auf die Ukraine
hatte von Anfang an auch massive Folgen
für das Russlandgeschäft der deutschen
Wirtschaft knapp drei von vier
Unternehmen haben es mittlerweile
ausgesetzt oder sich komplett
zurückgezogen insgesamt sind das gut
1000 Firmen jetzt zieht auch der Öl- und
Gaskonzern Winters halt der die
Reißleine und das kostet Milliarden
wintersaal gehört mehrheitlich dem
Ludwigshafener Chemie riesen BASF Jürgen
Kehl berichtet
lange nach dem Beginn des russischen
angriffskriegs auf die Ukraine wählt in
Sibirien noch deutsche Fahnen
Gasförderung durch wintersaldea doch
damit ist jetzt Schluss die Zentrale in
Kassel gibt heute bekannt das
Unternehmen beabsichtigt sich
vollständig aus Russland zurückzuziehen
die Joint Ventures also die
Beteiligungen in Russland wurden de
facto wirtschaftlich enteignet
überraschend ist eigentlich dass das
erst so spät passiert also dass man fast
ein Jahr nach Kriegsausbruch plötzlich
zu dem Schluss kommt dass ein Engagement
Russland nicht mehr in den eigenen
Werten entspricht eigentlich hätte man
diese Schlussfolgerung schon viel früher
ziehen können der Rückzug ist teuer es
geht um eine sogenannte Wertberichtigung
von 7,3 Milliarden Euro eine gewaltige
Summe die auch den Mutterkonzern BASF in
die verlustszone reist im letzten Jahr
freut man sich in Ludwigshafen noch über
satte 5,5 Milliarden Euro gewinnen jetzt
stehen 1,38 Milliarden Verlust in der
Bilanz Winterzeit eher fördert in
Russland nicht nur Öl und Gas Recherchen
im zdf-magazins frontal gemeinsam mit
dem Spiegel hatten offenbart dass der
Partner Gazprom gemeinsam gefördertes
Kondensat auch für die kerosinproduktion
nutzte für die russische Luftwaffe die
Politik hat auch deshalb auf den Rückzug
gedrängt die Entscheidung ist richtig
und überfällig denn wintersaal ist seit
2014 an der Finanzierung der russischen
Kriegskasse beteiligt insbesondere an
der Produktion von Kerosin für russische
Kriegsflugzeuge und russische
Kriegswaffen das sind
Milliardeninvestitionen über die jetzt
Russland verfügen wird immerhin der
deutschen Wirtschaft insgesamt droht
kein Schrecken ohne Ende von den ganz
großen Konzernen ist das komplette
Russlandgeschäft abgeschrieben bzw
beendet worden es gibt vielleicht nur
noch punktuell Auslandgeschäft das
Wasser deutsche Milliarden Investitionen
in Russland sie sind wohl erst einmal
Geschichte
und noch eine wirtschaftsnachricht die
Lufthansa will die staatliche
italienische Fluggesellschaft ita
Airways übernehmen und hat der
italienischen Regierung ein Angebot
unterbreitet zunächst geht es um eine
Minderheitsbeteiligung genaue Zahlen
wird weil der Preis wurden nicht
mitgeteilt
ita Airways ist Nachfolgerin der
jahrelang defizitären Alitalia
das EU-Parlament hat einen neuen
Vizepräsidenten eigentlich ist das eine
Randnotiz wenn nicht ein gewaltiger
Korruptions Skandal diese Wahl nötig
gemacht hätte Rückblick Anfang Dezember
werden die damalige Parlaments Vize Eva
Kylie und weitere Verdächtige
festgenommen in ihren Wohnungen finden
ihr Mittler insgesamt 1,5 Millionen Euro
Bargeld sie glauben die Verdächtigen
sind von Katha und Marokko gestochen
worden im Gegenzug sollen sie Politik im
Interesse dieser Länder gemacht haben
nicht die einzigen fragwürdigen
Praktiken in Brüssel wie Florian
herausgefunden hat
einen neuen Vizepräsidenten zu wählen
das ist dieser Tage noch die leichteste
Aufgabe für das Europaparlament Marc
Angel Sozialdemokrat aus Luxemburg hat
seinen Karriere Sprung von heute dem
korruptions-skandal zu verdanken und
seiner Vorgängerin evakali aus
Griechenland die nach
Korruptionsvorwürfen abgesetzt und immer
noch in Haft ist die Affäre Kata Gate
getauft erschüttert das Europaparlament
in seinem Grundfesten die Präsidentin
verspricht dem ZDF-Interview aufzuräumen
kann ich sagen dass so etwas nie wieder
passieren wird nein aber ich werde mein
bestes geben damit alle Schlupflöcher
geschlossen werden
was sie auch meint gesponserte
Dienstreisen dem ZDF liegt exklusiv eine
Auflistung aller Reisen vor die sich
Parlamentarier in dieser Legislatur von
Dritten bezahlen diesen rechtlich
zulässig politischer beiden dutzenden
Fällen fragwürdig etwa wenn die Reisen
von Regimen aus Russland Syrien oder
Katar bezahlt worden während die
Parlamentspräsidentin hier nur mehr
Transparenz gefordert verlangen andere
ein komplettes Verbot solcher Reisen
wer sich einladen lässt kann nicht
objektiv sein Abgeordnete stehen dann in
der Schuld ihres Gastgebers und zahlen
das mit politischen Gefälligkeiten
zurück gestern wurde derweil bekannt
dass der mutmaßliche Drahtzieher des
korruptions-skandals der ex-abgeordnete
Pierre Antonio panzeri einen Deal
geschlossen hat Strafmilderung gegen
Geständnis offenbar belastet er auch den
aktuellen belgischen Abgeordneten Mark
tarabella das EU-Parlament hat einen
neuen Vize die Affäre aber ist noch
lange nicht durch
und sie haben es eben im Beitrag sehen
können wir konnten exklusiv mit
eu-parlamentspräsidentin Mezzola über
die Korruptionsvorwürfe reden und das
ganze Interview das finden Sie in
unserer ZDF heute App
ungenügend diese Note würden sich viele
Schulen wahrscheinlich gerade selber
geben und das liegt am dramatischen
Lehrermangel das sei das problem Nummer
eins sagen zwei Drittel der Befragten
Schulleitungen im aktuellen
schul-barometer in Brennpunktschulen da
sind es sogar 80%, mit großem Abstand
folgen die schleppende Digitalisierung
und zu viel Bürokratie wie die
Bundesländer gegen den Lehrermangel
kämpfen dazu jetzt Isabella Vega
Ulrike Noll ist Direktorin einer
Darmstädter Grundschule kein leichter
Job aber es gibt Anlass zur Freude
Hessen hat entschieden die Bezahlung für
Grundschullehrer anzuheben von rund
3.600 auf gut 4.200 Euro ich denke es
werden jetzt mehr Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Lehramt für Grundschule
studieren und das andere ist das
natürlich die Abwanderung in andere
Bundesländer aufgehalten wird um
Lehrkräfte ist längst ein
Verteilungskampf zwischen den
Bundesländern entbrannt auch um künftige
wie die Studentin Eva Hörnig obwohl ich
zunächst davon überzeugt war in
Rheinland-Pfalz zu bleiben weil ich eben
aus Mainz bin bin ich jetzt doch am
überlegen in Hessen dann mein Lehrberuf
anzufangen und ähm ja das bleibt immer
noch offen aber es macht natürlich
attraktiver durch die
Gehaltserhöhung auch Bayern wird jetzt
offensiv mit einem guten Gehalt das
werden wir mit einem Paket für Stadt und
Umzugshilfe versehen das möglichst viele
nach einem erfolgreichen Studium in
Deutschland der Pädagogik des Lehrberufs
überlegen ob das nicht was wir in Bayern
zu machen die Zahl der
lehramtsabsolventen an deutschen Unis
ist aber im Vergleich zu vor zehn Jahren
um fast 14 Prozent gesunken wir brauchen
eine weitere Erhöhung der
studienplatzkapazitäten damit wir mehr
Lehrkräfte gewinnen wir brauchen nicht
Selbstverständnis aller Bundesländer
ihren für Ihren Bedarf auszubilden statt
sich gegenseitig die Lehrkräfte
abzuwerben doch die meisten Unis sind am
Limit woher die vielen neuen Lehrer
kommen sollen diese Frage hat die
Politik noch nicht beantwortet
nach einem Brand in einem Pflegeheim für
psychisch Kranke in Reutlingen ermittelt
die Polizei jetzt wegen des Verdachts
auf Mord im Fokus steht eine 57-jährige
Heimbewohnerin nach ersten Erkenntnissen
habe sie das Feuer gestern Abend in
Ihrem Wohnbereich selbst gelegt so die
Polizei drei Bewohner kamen ums Leben
die Verdächtige sowie 11 weitere
Personen wurden verletzt das Tatmotiv
ist doch völlig unklar
bei uns geht es jetzt sportlich weiter
und ein Lichtblick beim Tennis gibt's
Australian Open da ist eine deutsche
Spielerin welch große Erleichterung
Laura Siegemund steht als einzige
deutsche Frau in der zweiten Einzelrunde
beim ersten Grand Slam Turnier des
Jahres den Australian Open der Herz
gekämpft gegen die Italienerin Lucia
bronzetti und eine Schrecksekunde
weggesteckt
zu früh gejubelt schon ein Spiel vor dem
Matchball braches aus Laura Siegemund
heraus das kann auch eine erfahrenen
Spielerin mal passieren dann habe ich so
viele Sekunde irgendwie gedacht das
war's aber ist dann relativ schnell klar
geworden nee es geht noch weiter aber
auch der echte Matchball saß dann zum
Glück und Laura Siegemund konnte richtig
aufatmen denn zu Beginn noch in anderem
Outfit fand die Deutschen nicht in ihren
Rhythmus doch ihr Aufschlagspiel wurde
besser sie änderte ihre Taktik und ihr
gelang im dritten Satz ein offensives
und angriffslustiges Spiel
dann habe ich verdient mit Mut gewonnen
ihr Kampf hat sich gelohnt die
34-Jährige gewann ihr erst runden Match
in drei Sätzen
tja dagegen schmerzvolles aus in Runde 2
für Vorjahresgewinner Rafael Nadal der
Spanier kämpfte trotz Hüftverletzung bis
zum Schluss und musste letztlich arg
frustriert gegen McKenzie McDonald USA
eine Dreisatz Niederlage hinnehmen
der Wechsel von Gladbach Torhüter Jan
Sommer zum FC Bayern München ist laut
Medienberichten perfekt die Borussia und
der Rekordmeister sollen sich auf einen
sofortigen Transfer geeinigt haben es
fehlen nur noch der Medizincheck
und beste Stimmung bei den Deutschen
Handballern bei der Weltmeisterschaft im
polnischen Kattowitz drei Spiele drei
Siege das stärkt das Selbstbewusstsein
und den Teamgeist
feiern konnte man beim DHB heute gleich
doppelt den verlust.freien Einzug in die
Hauptrunde und den 33 Geburtstag von
Nationalspieler Christoph Steinert
Bundestrainer alfred gieslersson hatte
gegen Algerien vor allem dem zweiten
Anzug eine Chance gegeben Spielminuten
zu sammeln und konnte so gleichzeitig
die erste Garde schonen nun warten mit
Argentinien die Niederlanden und
Norwegen die hauptrundeten Gegner es
gibt keine leichten Gegner
Weltmeisterschaft in der Hauptrunde ja
und wir tun gut daran uns jetzt
vorzubereiten wie immer egal gehen gegen
wen es geht die erste Aufgabe für das
DHB-Team bereits morgen Abend das Spiel
gegen die Argentinier
morgen abend 18 Uhr heißt das und ich
nehme mit manchmal umziehen beim Tennis
hilft allerdings lange Klamotten hat sie
angefangen
so haben Sie wahrscheinlich auch
mitbekommen vom Winter fehlt seit Wochen
jede Spur aber jetzt hat sich das
Winterwetter wieder breit gemacht mit
frostigen Temperaturen und Neuschnee
endlich winter wonderland am Fichtelberg
im Erzgebirge endlich wieder einen
Schneemann bauen oder aber mit dem
Schlitten den Hang hinab Düsen darauf
haben sie hier sehnsüchtig gewartet auch
wenn es nicht ganz ohne beschneiden ging
im größten Skigebiet von Sachsen
so wir hätten noch die Zahlen vom
Mittwochslotto die Gewinnzahlen lauten 1
8 21 25 37 46 und die Superzahl 9
weitere Gewinnzahlen auf lotto.zdf.de
oder auf der ZDF Textseite 557
ob und wo Schnee nachkommt gleich von
Katja hornefer um 21 Uhr 45 gibt es
heute journal mit Marietta Slomka das
war es von uns an diesem Mittwoch wir
von der 19 Uhr heute sagen danke fürs
zuschauen wünsche noch einen entspannten
Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend dieses kleine tief hat eine
gewisse Ähnlichkeit mit tropischen
Wirbelstürmen denn wenn sie ganz genau
hinschauen dann sehen sie ein kleines
wolkenfreies Auge dieses Tief wird bis
morgen weiter über Dänemark Richtung
Ostseeküste ziehen für uns interessant
aktuell sind noch die dichteren Wolken
zwischen der Ostsee und dem Bodensee
Schnee bringen die in der Nacht
allerdings kaum noch mit vielleicht am
Alpenrand und hier in der Lausitz und
dann kommt das neue Tiefe an bringt
schon heute Nacht Schnee und Schnee
Regen sie sollten sich also auf
rutschige Straßen gefasst machen denn
die Temperaturen sinken auf plus 1 bis
-9 Grad und morgen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen am Alpenrand und in
der Mittelgebirge im leichten Dauerfrost
sonst werden zarte plus gerade erreicht
und im Nordwesten steigen die Werte auf
vier bis sechs Grad Schnee und Schnee
Regen ziehen morgen langsam weiter nach
Osten und hier in der Ostsee pfeift der
Wind stark bis stürmisch aus
südwestlichen Richtungen an der Nordsee
kannst doch mal für ein Gewitter reichen
und an der Ostseeküste und den
Erzgebirge wie auch südlich der Donau
wird es ganz freundlich in den nächsten
Tagen geht es winterlich weiter und dann
kommt der Schnee mehr und mehr aus Osten
guten Abend